To those politicians supported by the NRA
that allow the continued slaughter of our
children and our future
I say 'get your resumes ready.'
The students of Stoneman Douglas High School
in Parkland, Florida
have reenergized the national movement to
restrict gun ownership
following the tragic mass shooting that claimed
17 lives.
The culmination of this movement was the massive
March for Our Lives Rally in Washington, D.C.
I'm here to help stop gun violence.
I just think enough is enough and I don't
want to see any more lives being lost.
I want less children to die.
We can and we will change the world.
The students from Stoneman Douglas have earned
praise for their leadership
in demanding that Congress take decisive action.
But there’s another consequence of this
movement,
which is that the Parkland mass shooting
seems to be stoking irrational fear about
gun violence in schools.
I'm here 'cause I want to feel safe in my
school.
You’d come away from the March for Our Lives
thinking that there’s a mass shooting epidemic
in American schools.
I do think that it's more dangerous in schools.
There's more school shootings now.
We're all in danger.
But what happened at Stoneman Douglas was
an extremely rare occurrence.
American schools are profoundly safe, and
most likely getting safer:
According to researchers at Northeastern University,
shooting incidents involving students have
actually decreased in recent years,
and in the 1990s the overall crime rate was
much higher than it is today.
The rate of homicides from firearms in the
U.S. has plummeted.
In fact, students are orders of magnitude
more likely to die in a car crash
on their way to school
than they are to be gunned down in their classrooms.
Yet the protesters were demanding more security
in schools—a lot more
So do you think there should be more police
officers in schools?
Yeah, definitely.
Trained officers or security guards should
be the ones protecting students.
—even if it means making armed guards a
fixture of the lives of children.
I support sensible gun policy.
It's simple, no guns, less violence.
We should stop having guns anywhere at all
like I feel like guns should be outlawed.
I would just like to see guns illegal.
This latest hysteria over mass shootings and
guns
is leading to claims that we must relinquish
our rights in the name of safety,
which is a familiar story, from the drug war
to the war on terror.
Teenagers have every right to fight for a
cause they believe in,
and the students from Stoneman Douglas are
justifiably enraged
about an event that claimed the lives of so
many friends and classmates.
But feelings shouldn’t trump facts
and we should never craft policies from a
place of fear in the wake of tragedy.
There should be more regulations, or there
should just be more laws
there just needs to be something happening,
thoughts and prayers don't do much anymore.
It's just, I'm just getting tired of it.